[Música]
El Congreso de Perú rechaza por tercera
vez la posibilidad de adelantar las
elecciones para 2023 la mayoría de los
legisladores no estuvieron de acuerdo en
votar conjuntamente el adelanto de los
comicios y la propuesta de asamblea
Constituyente detalles con nuestro
corresponsal en
Lima en Ecuador comenzaron las
votaciones de las elecciones seccionales
y las ocho reformas constitucionales que
promueve el gobierno de Guillermo lasso
y los comicios iniciaron en 35 cárceles
del país convocando a casi 5.500
personas que aún no tienen una sentencia
en contra y por lo tanto gozan de
derechos políticos
los republicanos de Estados Unidos le
ganaron una batalla a los demócratas de
la cámara baja los lograron la mayoría
para expulsar del comité de asuntos
exteriores a la representante Ilan oward
ellos la acusan por comentarios que la
representante hizo contra Israel pero
los demócratas alegan que fue una
venganza por la salida previa de dos
republicanos
Bienvenidos a las noticias que France 24
le dedica a América Mi nombre es María
Clara calle
empezamos en Perú porque el congreso
rechazó el proyecto de ley que promovió
el partido izquierdista Perú libre para
adelantar las elecciones generales a
Julio de 2023 y además realizar una
consulta sobre si hacer o no una
asamblea Constituyente Esta es la
segunda propuesta que hunden los
legisladores en una semana después de
votar negativamente en dos ocasiones un
proyecto anterior que pretendía
establecer la fecha de los comicios para
diciembre de 2023 desde Lima a nuestro
corresponsal Francisco Zacarías nos
explicó Qué opciones le quedan Entonces
al gobierno de Dina boluarte para
adelantar las elecciones
Bueno al gobierno de Dina boluarte le
queda la única salida de insistir con el
proyecto que ha presentado el Primer
Ministro Alberto tarola al parlamento
peruano precisamente la comisión de
Constitución ha citado al Primer
Ministro peruano a que acuda el día que
ha sido citado que va a ser dentro de
unas horas se va a abrir este caso en la
comisión del congreso para que el Primer
Ministro detalle Cuál es el alcance en
sí de la iniciativa pero muchos
analistas están diciendo que eso va a
ser un alargue porque la comisión de
Constitución va a tener luego que
debatir la aprobarla y enviarla a la
comisión permanente esta Va a ser el
mismo proceso para enviarla al pleno del
parlamento peruano y someter la votación
muchos están vaticinando que el
parlamento no va a aprobar esto y al
gobierno de boluarte le va a quedar
enviar al Primer Ministro a hacer
cuestión de confianza para que se
apruebe la
en Ecuador el jueves comenzaron las
votaciones de las elecciones seccionales
las del Consejo de participación
ciudadana y las de ocho reformas
constitucionales que promueven el
gobierno de Guillermo lasso aunque los
comicios son El domingo 5 de febrero
casi 5.500 presos pudieron votar en 35
cárceles del país pues aún no pierden
sus derechos políticos por no tener una
sentencia en contra las urnas de las
prisiones estarán selladas hasta el
conteo general del domingo y la
protagonista es la consulta popular que
impulsa El Ejecutivo previamente desde
quito nuestro corresponsal Gustavo
Ortega nos contó En qué consisten las
ocho reformas propuestas por el gobierno
y que se espera que suceda
bueno el gobierno ha presentado ocho
preguntas para una reforma
constitucional ha pasado todo un proceso
luego de calificación por parte de la
corte constitucional Pero en qué
consiste son básicamente ocho preguntas
algunas relacionadas con temas de
seguridad como la extradición la
consulta para que el pueblo ecuatoriano
decida si está de acuerdo con la
extradición de Ecuatorianos inmersos en
delitos de narcotráfico tráfico de armas
trata de personas para su extradición
hay otras preguntas también que tiene
que ver en cuanto a la autonomía de la
fiscalía hay otras también relacionadas
con el número de asambleístas reducir el
número de asambleístas De igual forma
también lo que sería la base fundamental
de la Reforma constitucional si es
también la de reducir las capacidades de
Selección del Consejo de participación
ciudadana y control Social es un
organismo de control creado como tú bien
lo dijiste en el año 2008 para la
selección de autoridades este organismo
selecciona 77 autoridades altos cargos y
el gobierno nacional ha insistido que no
ha sido efectivo y De igual forma
también ha estado inmerso en debates
para poder seleccionar Qué pasará bueno
se realizan también estas elecciones en
marco de una investigación un escándalo
de supuesta estructura de corrupción que
señala a el cuñado al presidente de la
república Y esto ha hecho más
competitivo podría ser más competitivo
el voto El Ejecutivo nacional ha
intentado separar la campaña electoral
del propio presidente el lazo para
distanciarse un poco de el principal
involucrado su cuñado Danilo Carrera
mala Clara
pasamos a Estados Unidos con 218 votos a
favor y 211 en contra los republicanos
de la cámara baja ganaron su propuesta
para expulsar a la representante y la
nouma del comité de asuntos exteriores
esta musulmana nacida en somalia fue
señalada por unos comentarios que
publicó contra Israel pero los
demócratas alegan que es un ataque
racista y una venganza política Pues por
primera vez en 2021 la mayoría demócrata
destituyó de dos comités a los
ultraderechistas Marjorie Taylor Win y
Paul gozar el informe lo tiene Muñoz
los republicanos se hacen notar en la
cámara de representantes y este martes
hicieron valer su mayoría para expulsar
a la demócrata y la nahumar de la
comisión de asuntos exteriores de la
cámara
para ser claros una representante puede
decir lo que quiera pero no tenemos que
aceptarlo las personas que tienen
opiniones tan odiosas deberían ser
excluidas de este tipo de comité
los republicanos achacan a Omar seis
declaraciones especialmente un tuit de
2019 que un mar borro y por el que
después se disculpó el tuit decía que
todo se trata de los benjamins una
referencia al billete de 100 dólares de
Benjamin Franklin con el que insinuaba
que Los partidarios de Israel Solo
piensan en el dinero Omar se defendió
no en el congreso para guardar silencio
viene el congreso para hacer su voz y mi
liderazgo y mi voz No disminuirán si no
estoy en este comité por un periodo mi
voz será más y más fuerte y mi liderazgo
será celebrado en todo el mundo como lo
ha sido
la expulsión se suma a la negativa del
líder de la mayoría republicana Kevin
mccarthy a que los demócratas erickwell
y Adam shift hagan parte de la comisión
de inteligencia decisiones vistas como
retaliaciones por las expulsiones de los
republicanos Marjorie Taylor Green y
Paul gozar en 2021 cuando los demócratas
tenían mayoría por retórica incendiaria
los compañeros de Omar salieron en su
defensa
colegas me presento ante ustedes como
una orgullosa judía y una orgullosa
amiga y colega de Dylan Omar
Omar llegó a Estados Unidos como
refugiada desde somalia es la única
congresista nacida en África y una de
las pocas mujeres musulmanas de la
cámara de representantes forma parte de
los nueve representantes demócratas
conocidos Como the squat por su carácter
progresista y por su juventud
en Brasil un congresista está acusando
al expresidente Jair bolsonaru de estar
un plan para evitar que Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva se posesionara el primero
de enero de este año el senador de
Centro izquierda Marcos dubal afirma que
en diciembre de 2022 se reunió con
bolsonaro y con el diputado Daniel
silveira segundo baal le pidieron que
grabara ilegalmente al presidente del
tribunal superior electoral Alexandre de
morach y hacerlo caer en una
contradicción de esa manera lograrían
que demoraesh fuera arrestado y así Lula
no podría tomar posesión los mensajes
los publicó la revista bella sin embargo
nobal se contradice por ejemplo cuando
menciona el lugar donde ocurrió la
reunión y sobre si bolsonaro lo instó
directamente al golpe o solo estuvo allí
para escuchar el plan escuchemos parte
de lo que denuncia
la idea era que colocaran el equipo de
grabación habría un vehículo cerca del
tribunal supremo grabando el audio y yo
en esta reunión con el ministro
Alexandre lo llevaría a decir que en
algunos de los procesos traspasó la
línea de la Constitución y de inmediato
dije que no haría eso no haría ese tipo
de cosas y le dije mire presidente y
Daniel esto es ilegal para hacer esta
grabación Ustedes deben tener
autorización del juez y terminamos con
noticias de fútbol americano a pesar de
que el Mariscal de campo Tom Brady
anunció por segunda vez que se va a
retirar ahora su antiguo equipo los New
england patreons quieran hacerle un
contrato para que juegue un partido más
así lo dio a conocer Robert Craft el
propietario de los paters en una
entrevista con la cadena CNN Craft
afirmó que harán todo lo que esté en su
poder para traerlo de regreso en un
juego más y honrarlo por las 20
temporadas que estuvo con el equipo y
con el que Brady ganó 6 de sus siete
super bowls para conseguir este objetivo
los Patriots tendrían que esperar por lo
menos hasta el 15 de marzo cuando se
abre el mercado de los agentes libres ya
que Brady todavía está vinculado con los
tampaniers
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con France
[Música]